dis-moi après l'assassinat du préfet de
Corse Claude Erignac l'enquête progresse
selon son successeur Bernard Bonnet
après de nombreuses interpellations dans
les milieux nationalistes agricoles cinq
membres du syndicat des enseignants
corps sont été arrêtés cette semaine une
nouvelle voie une nouvelle piste pour
les enquêteurs Michel Field en fait ce
n'est pas à proprement parler une
nouvelle piste c'est plutôt ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une piste
complémentaire les enquêteurs de la
division nationale antiterroriste sont
partis sur un tuyau DRG une indiscrétion
désignant quelques intellectuels de la
mouvance nationaleiste en particulier un
prof d'histoire géo d'une trentaine
d'années qui s'appelle Philippe Castella
les policiers auraient retrouvé chez lui
des plans des traces de repérage
effectuées pour préparer un attentat
commis sur le continent contre un
rectorat cet attentat aurait été commis
contre la vie de la direction du FLNC
canal historique qui aurait exclu à ce
moment-là Philippe Castella ce prof
d'histoire-géo est donc un dissident du
mouvement et c'est intéressant chez lui
les policiers auraient retrouvé des
éléments pour le moins troublant en
particulier un ordinateur et une
imprimante du même type que ceux qui ont
permis de rédiger et d'imprimer le texte
revendiquant l'assassinat du préfet
Reignac attention en aucun cas ce n'est
une preuve car les spécialistes de
l'informatique sont aujourd'hui
incapables de dire si c'est cet
imprimante précisément qui a édité ou
non la revendication mais c'est un
élément les juges antiterroriste vont
mettre en examen Philippe Castella il
s'intéresse désormais à ses
fréquentations ils veulent savoir s'il
était proche de certains agriculteurs de
la pleine orientale en Corse eux aussi
dissidents du FLNC canal historique car
ce qu'on a appelé la piste agricole
cette fameuse piste explorée depuis le
début par les magistrats et les
policiers cette piste n'est pas
abandonnée merci Michel le film